hello  good evening everybody  [Applause]  just offering you all a greeting in my  own Apache language tonight as we kick  things off  my name is bird running water and I'm  honored to stand before you this evening  representing the Cheyenne and Mescalero  Apache tribes the academy and the  members of the Academy's indigenous  Alliance  thank you  Tonight We Gather to celebrate  accomplishments and contributions to our  Governor's Awards recipients we do so on  the ancestral lands of the tongva people  the original caretakers of this water  and land  we honored  to tongue the ancestors the tongva  community today which continues to  nurture this land in water through  traditional practices activism art and  education we also acknowledge and offer  our respect to indigenous communities  around the world  the original storytellers and Foundation  of our Global Motion Picture Community  thank you  now please join me in welcoming to the  stage Academy president Janet yang